- And that's why think I'm
giving you good advice because
I think your maturity manifests
professionally into something
that looks like the
part that I just told you.
And that's when a street
hustler makes 130 million.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
Hey. Such a pleasure.
- And when I heard your
interview on the Breakfast Club
that time, and I mentioned
this at the holiday party.
- [Gary] I remember.
- I'm just like
listen, this guy has,
like, you pump me up.
You let me
know stop, you know--
- [Gary] Crying about it.
- making excuses for yourself.
Like, you're not at
the place you want to be,
that's fine.
But make changes.
You know, do what
you have to do.
- [Gary] You have
so much control.
- Mhmmm.
- [Gary] People don't feel it.
- [Juliet] Mhmmm.
- But they do.
- And the game is
not interested in,
that game is not interested
in making it easy for you.
- [Juliet] Mhmmm.
- Especially when
you've got points against you.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] The problem
is there's just no choice.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
I think there's a lot of
ways to think about this.
I would tell you to meet as
many people here as possible.
I mean people is the game.
Right?
- [Juliet] Yeah.
So like right in house?
- Right in house, cafeteria.
Like work out of the
cafeteria for an hour every day.
Because it's the people, right?
- [Juliet] Mhmmm.
- Like it's some 22-year-old guy
right now who's eventually gonna
have his own business.
Some 24-year-old girl
that's gonna be in politics,
it's a human that's gonna create
the most rich
opportunities and friendships.
I think that
would be game changing.
What do you do? Hey.
Or if you're in a good meeting
where you just said Pinterest
and you like the vibe of that
person who knows what she or he
does, as you walk out be like,
"Hey, thanks for the
love in that room.
"Like you made me feel good.
"Hey, let's get a drink after
work one day or you want to get
"a coffee or you want to
lunch one day together?"
Just be on the offense.
I genuinely, genuinely believe
that people are scared to not be
nice here because they know
I give a fuck so much about it,
and I think you should
take advantage of that.
- [Juliet] Okay. Awesome.
- Cool.
- [Juliet] Thank you.
- Have a great day.
- [Juliet] It was
very nice to meet you.
- Yeah, such a pleasure.
Take care. Have the best day.
- [Juliet] Yes, you too.
- Take care, Juliet.
- [Skyler] Hey, how you doing?
- Hey Skyler.
I'm doing really well, man.
How are you?
- [Skyler] Doing alright.
- [Gary] Good, man.
How long you been here?
- [Skyler] Since July.
- Awesome, how's it goin'?
- [Skyler] Doing great.
- Good.
- [Skyler] Really,
really enjoy it.
- Tell me about yourself.
Hi. How are you?
- [Chelsea] Hi, I'm Chelsea.
- [Gary] Chelsea, I'm Gary.
- [Chelsea] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
How was your weekend?
- [Chelsea] It was nice.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
- [Gary] 'Sup Mike?
- [Mike] Gary how are you?
Good, brother, how are you?
- [Mike] Good.
- [Gary] Good man.
- [Mike] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] I like your shirt.
- [Mike] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Mike] One of my
designers is wearing it,
too so we're sitting
there looking at each other.
- (laughs) Is that a bad day
to wear the same shirt?
I think it's kinda cool.
- When you work with somebody
everyday and in meetings,
and you wear the same outfit.
When the girls do it,
I try to turn it into
a who wore it better.
- Yeah.
How about when the guys?
- I just try to distance myself.
- (laughs) You gonna
avoid him all day.
- [Mike] Yeah.
- Love it, brother.
So this is the
Honey Empire thing.
It's not just build the
greatest business of all time.
Like build a $4.3 billion
revenue business and be nice.
There's all these
things in-between.
And one of the in-betweens are
things like the alumni program.
Like what if I built one of
the great businesses of this
generation and what that meant
was every one of those fuckers
out there had an alumni program.
- [Mike] Mhmmm.
- Which is offense.
- [Mike] It is. (inaudible)
- Yeah, and it's
offense instead of defense.
Like I want to know what
everybody's thinking but I have
no fucking clue
what you're thinking.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
The analogy I
usually give is like
we're a 14-year-old supermodel
which means we're 6-foot-1 and
we have zits and braces and
we're still getting made fun of
by the same guys who are gonna
rip their arms off to date us in
seven years.
- [Mike] Mhmmm.
- That's the punchline.
- [Mike] Okay.
- That's straight up.
Now, being better than being a
14-year-old supermodel is I can
speed up that process.
I just don't have
to wait six more years.
You know what I mean?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- [Gary] Exactly, I don't have
to wait four more years for me
to become the swan.
I'm doing everything I can
to make that happen quicker.
But I don't get crippled
by the medium-term, right?
I like tasting and seeing
and watching, you know?
It's about talent.
It's about meritocracy.
It's about doing.
It's about being smarter.
A lot of things that I think are
gonna make a lot of sense to you
while making sure we do not
replicate where you came from
'cause I have zero interest.
("Up In Smoke - Instrumental"
by Andrew Triple A)
So, first of all, you're about
to get really happy with me.
'Cause I have the funny feeling
you're the kind of character
that's about to really make some
money on what I'm about to say.
Some reason my "Spidey senses",
to stay in the comic book theme,
says to me cool, before we get
into the cliche answers I could
give you, which are probably
right about how to figure out
making it worth something
and like what's the balance of
building a personal brand and IP
and giving away and not giving
away which is all right you
should sleep on one other thing.
Which is I think you can
actually build (censored).
- [Man] Like go a
completely different direction.
- I think you can
actually go all the way.
I think you're young enough and
potentially balanced out by the
humility of your experience,
have the right balance of
humility and magic to at least
challenge yourself over the next
little piece of time of
could I build (censored)?
I'm a player (censored) there's
no (censored) when I was a kid.
Nobody owns it or
maybe somebody does,
I'm out of the game.
Okay, five minutes.
I'm really good for giving
you advice because we almost
basically lived the
same life, so we share DNA.
It's the ultimate arbitrage.
You make your money by
arbitraging within the system.
You could arbitrage the system.
Panini did.
- [Man] Yeah.
- After you do your
homework and you're like okay,
when I'm 42 years old
in seven years, he's right.
This is actually
gonna be as big as UFC.
Bro, if we were
sitting here in 1963,
the NFL was shit.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Dude, the 1983 NBA
Finals was on tape delay.
And that's why think I'm giving
you good advice because I think
your maturity manifests
professionally into something
that looks like the
part that I just told you.
And that's when a street
hustler makes 130 million.
I've figured that out.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You know?
Cool.
My man, real pleasure.
Yeah, we'll do that.
Thank you.
("Up In Smoke - Instrumental"
by Andrew Triple A)
Is that Steve Ross?
Yes.
Yeah, that's definitely Ross.
Nobody else gets to
cross their hands across this.
Can we get in here?
- [Steve] Hey.
- [Gary] Need me to
get in here? Let's do it.
- [Man 2] Wow, you want that?
That's great. That's great.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Steve] Good. How you doin'?
- [Gary] Do you know that he
fell for the April Fool's joke?
That I'm working out and
he rolls up on me and goes,
"Steve got
voted out of the NFL."
(Steve laughs)
Did you see that?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] All well?
- Things couldn't be better.
- [Gary] This is nice.
- [Tyler] Tyler Schmitt.
- [Gary] Tyler's my assistant.
- Oh, seen you.
- [Gary] Hey, how are you?
Doing some photos?
This is DRock, he
films all my stuff.
You good?
- [Steven] You're filming?
Were you filming now for--
- [Gary] My vlog!
You're gonna be on it again.
- your vlog?
- You're like one of
the favorite characters
of the whole thing.
(Steve laughs)
It's good to see you.
See you soon?
- [Steve] Yeah, definitely.
- Yeah. Cool.
- [DRock] Bye.
- How you doin', Phil?
Really good. Yeah.
- [Tyler] There's Avi.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
- [Gary] Cool.
Yeah, that's how you do.
One step at a time.
How's it going?
Glad we finally
made this happen.
- [Dean] Yeah, me too.
Me too, I appreciate it.
Tyler was great to deal with.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
Be with you in a sec.
So the next one will be?
- I can give you the tour.
- [Gary] Yeah,
give me the nickel tour.
Good to see you.
Hey!
- [Woman] Hey Gary!
How are you?
- [Gary] How are ya?
- Nice to meet ya, man.
Good to see ya.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
(glass ringing)
- [Woman 2] Gary
wants attention.
- Susan, I like your sneakers.
- [Susan] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Susan] I have heels,
I'm not gonna lie.
- Smart.
(crosstalk)
So, it seems like
everybody's yapping.
I just want to
give a little framework.
We've got a bunch of
really good wine which
I selected for tonight.
There's oysters and shrimp and
things of that nature and so
I want to make sure
that everybody knows that.
And so come over and grab some.
We'll hang here for another 15,
20 minutes and then we're gonna
go out back and have dinner.
So, I just want
to thank everybody.
I'm really glad
we did this again.
I really like this little
thing as our little thing
and so have fun.
We'll get in there in a little
bit but please grab some food
'cause the oysters
and shrimp are a big deal.
- [Susan] Thank
you for having us.
- [Gary] My pleasure.
I'm really glad you're here.
Yeah, for sure. Cheers. Enjoy.
- [All] Cheers.
- [Gary] Grab a plate, please.
I'm gonna go first
'cause I love oysters.
Alright, now
we're gonna go into
a little session
with our clients.
You know, I'm a big fan of
shaking hands
and kissing babies.
I think that for
you guys who follow me,
you may be confused
about how I think about
technology and real life.
I believe that technology is
a gateway drug
to real life, right?
We roll in DM and hang out
on Twitter and then we end up
shaking hands and hugging
it out and taking selfies.
I think that's important with
clients and my organization.
There's a bunch of
people that work for me here.
people that are my clients.
They're equally important.
Actually, the employees are
a little bit more important.
But the punchline
is being together,
hanging, jamming,
meeting new friends,
that's the key.
And that's what I'm gonna
allocate my time to the rest of
the night.
So, DRock, I love you,
get out of here.
("Otherside" by Hi-Rez)
Alright guys, great night.
Good biz dev, Avi's out of here.
I'm outta here.
We'll see you tomorrow night.